now that is what I call Ham it's got a
little bit of juice
Tick Tock food star Taylor claydorum
known as waffler69 has died he was 33
years old
[Music]
in hand
that's perfect let's go cook the rest
Taylor's brother Clayton shared the sad
news on Tick Tock he believes Taylor
died of a heart attack I'm related to
welfare 69 or my brother Taylor
uh
he has passed away
around 10 p.m on January 11 2023
from a presumed heart attack
he was rushed to the hospital and I want
to say like an hour an hour and a half
later he passed away now this is still
pretty new I don't know what's going to
be happening in the near future with any
of that
but I thought I should get on
Tick Tock and let everybody know Taylor
has 1.7 million followers on Tick Tock
he's best known for uploading reviews of
wild and strange foods like this we've
got rattlesnake in a can today let's see
if this is a trick or a treat I see why
it's only sampled because it is not
pleasing
oh it's make my fingers stink
canned rattlesnake is just one of many
Taylors also tried turkey soda it's got
a beautiful caramel color
why is it salty it doesn't taste like
turkey or gravy too heavy though his
brother organized a GoFundMe to help
their mother pay for funeral costs
please keep his legacy alive watch his
content that he does have out
um keep him alive
um he loved making people happy
[Music]